la famille jean pierre est à la
recherche d'un véhicule d'occasion il
s'a prince ma voiture mais ce que gm a
lâché hier problèmes de transmission
l'auto était quand même assez âgés donc
ça valait pas la bête de mettre l'argent
dessus elle s'est donc tournée vers
cette toyota corolla 2013 à fort prix
dans les circonstances puisque il est
presque impossible de repartir avec les
clés d'une voiture neuve chez un
concessionnaire automobile si le taux
est m'était destinée les voitures
d'occasion s'envolent comme des petits
pains chauds ce qui crée une véritable
frénésie phil et claire elle avait vécu
là bas ça déplacé parce que il y aura
pas d' harvey la réalité les manders de
ce concessionnaire n'a jamais été aussi
bas il a une trentaine de véhicules
d'occasion à vendre alors qu'il a de la
place pour 150 c'est une conséquence
directe de la pandémie
alors que de nombreux constructeurs ont
dû freiner brusquement leur production
ajoutez à cela la pénurie de semi
conducteurs et vous avez la tempête
parfaite pour retarder la livraison de
véhicules neufs les consommateurs se
tournent donc vers les voitures de
seconde main où il y en a déjà aussi
présentement nous avons des véhicules
parce qu'attendre véhicules neufs
électrique ou autre fait qui nous attend
véhicule pour la
kyria sa patiente et par leurs véhicules
neufs c'est au québec que l'augmentation
du prix d'un véhicule d'occasion il a
plus marqué 43 % en avril
comparativement à l'an dernier prix
moyen de 35 mille 137 dollars selon
autohebdo long là on n'a pas assez là qu
on est sur le plateau puis savoir
descendre nécessairement parce que c'est
de l'économie un pur c'est l'offre et la
demande le québec est la province dont
l'inventaire de véhicules neufs a le
moins augmenté au pays l'an dernier à
moins d'une grande nécessité patienter
avant de vous acheter une voiture du ca
1 et pour ceux qui louent leur véhicule
on leur achète on profite de la valeur
résiduelle
garantie qui était inscrite au bail qui
est souvent plus basse que la valeur
marchande on leur achète on résiste à la
tentation de faire un coup d'argent et
on le conserve ici gérant bergeron radio
canada n'ont rien